by authority of the Lord's Alliance this
Absolution Council will now come to
order in the case of edgin Darvis and
Holger Kilgore
this is the second year of incarceration
for the crimes of grand larceny and
skull duggery it is the task of this
Council to determine your eligibility
for power what say you
thank you Chancellor anderton
steam members of the council
before I begin I I noticed that
Chancellor Jonathan is not present
should we perhaps wage Chancellor
Jonathan was delayed by the storm you
may begin I see it's just that I we were
really counting on him
to attend again or wave your statement
very well
I should start by giving you some
context
you may be surprised to learn I wasn't
always a thief
years ago I became a member of the
Harpers faction a network of spies who
swear an oath to fight tyranny defend
the oppressed and to ask nothing in
return my wife Zia supported my decision
even though she knew the risks
by day ideas drop on Mercenaries
stop bandits in their tracks
and even bring fan red Wizards to
Justice
By Night I'd come home to my loving wife
and daughter Kira
Giannis there were times when I began to
question the asking nothing in return
part of my oath
but my wife would always say you don't
have to give us everything you only have
to give us you so what's latest on
Jonathan is he close by because I can
wait did you not hear what we said right
the storm it's just that based on what I
know about Jonathan I think he'd be
especially receptive to my story and I'd
hate to have to wait a whole other year
to come back in here and after proceed
absolutely here we go when you were a
Harper you were bound to make enemies
and sometimes those enemies come looking
for Revenge
[Music]
foreign
can repair the damage from a red
Wizard's blade
there was no way to revive her
when Zia died
so did my devotion to my oath
[Music]
I'm sorry it's just
hard to relive this
without Jonathan here I came with this
but he missed the most important part of
my backstory how can he judge me without
knowing my my motivation we are entirely
capable of deciding your case without
Jonathan get on with it fine where was I
uh by night I come home to my loving
wife and daughter Kira you went back too
far stop stalling right sorry uh yeah
broad Strokes the next few months were
among my most shameful
that's when I met hoga
she took pity on me
well she took pity on the baby
holga was a fellow resident of rock
bottom
many years before she'd been cast out of
her tribe for falling in love with an
outsider
we quickly became like brother and
sister with a relationship built on
trust and mutual respect
neither of us had money or an honest way
to earn it so we decided to table honest
and we tried something new
it's intoxicating when you realize that
what separates you from what you've
always wanted can be as thin as a pane
of glass
foreign
you may be wondering how we could carry
on this criminal lifestyle with a young
girl at home
well we didn't leave her at home
Carol wasn't the only new recruit we
also added Simon a so-so sorcerer a con
man named Forge who pushed us to aim
even higher
before long we became a team
we're thieves but I tried to hold us to
a certain standard we never harmed
anyone and we only robbed from those who
would feel it the least
but everything changed when we met the
wizard sophina
we knew almost nothing about her only
that she wanted our help in robbing
Corn's keep that's a Harper stronghold I
don't know if you've heard of it I'm
sure Jonathan has
the keep was filled with a Priceless
Relic seized from evildoers and only
Harpers could gain access to the vault
which is why sufina came to us
at first I refused I wouldn't stoop that
low
but then Forge told me that among the
relics and Corn's keep there was a
tablet of Reawakening capable of
bringing back a single deceased person
even when killed by a red Wizard's blade
you can probably see where this is going
why can't I come sorry cure this one's
too dangerous then you shouldn't go
we have everything that we need not yet
but this is the the last one
trust me
chin upload we'll be right back I didn't
tell her about the tablet it would break
her heart if it all went and uh
it went
[Music]
come on
we don't hurt anyone
[Music]
she's caught the time
stuffing is too powerful
thank you
[Music]
Godly keep Kira safe
have my work
[Music]
the truth is even if this counsel were
to sentence me to another two years or
20 for that matter
it would never be punishment enough for
the worst crime I ever committed
robbing my daughter of her father
but know that if you do choose to free
me
I'll spend the rest of my days trying to
write that wrong
anything you want to add
I'm good
before you announce your decision I
implore you to please wait for
hold on now
oh Jonathan
but we approved your pardon
[Music]
fly